[Music]
one of the things that I need to expand
on in a in a 20-17 marketing
conversation is the variable of Facebook
creative in its ROI something that is
I'm tapping into is that 90% of digital
execution is garbage and so I think a
lot of people hear me talk and they
don't hear that I say do Superbowl
because I think it's under placed
attention I think they don't hear me say
do live read i heart radio because
radios under priced and I think what
they do here is that Facebook is
magically going to work because it's
under priced attention that is true
Facebook will give you the best that bat
in my opinion to hit all Americans at
the best price the problem is the
creative if it's a shitty kind of blurry
picture if it's a if it's a picture from
a print ad if it's a video that uses a
pre-roll advertising or a video that you
that was actually your TV commercial
you're gonna lose cuz the creative is
the variable once you have my attention
you've got to get me excited to buy your
thing and we have not had enough
conversation in the marketplace around
the modern Facebook commercial this one
two three four five minute video that is
a story that is compelling people to get
excited about a product or service or
mission and and I feel like I've even
been to general and I will push harder
much harder to make sure that people
recognize how important that creative is
and that's when you know just red shoe
pulp Tania's spending more money on
television and I'm just sitting here
saying okay
they definitely could have done better
if they put all that media money and to
tell them into Facebook I just genuinely
believe that
but I was like but why would television
work better than Facebook if that was a
bake-off and the answer is even though
it be still gonna be a crappy 30-second
commercial it is absolutely true that
they could have made a very crappy even
crappier even crappier commercial video
on Facebook and then that would be the
reason that television could outperform
Facebook in a here's four million
dollars here's four million dollars
bake-off the creative is the variable
and and that debate and and our
attention to the good creative and the
great videos that drive business results
needs to absolutely happen for marketers
big and small to be successful in the
new environment
[Music]